hey this is fresh talker you're given a
test where you have to match each
mathematician to that mathematicians
correct
Berthier but because you were never
taught about these mathematicians you
guess randomly by matching the five
names to five years the question is what
is your expected number of correct
answers if you can solve that problem to
need you can solve the generalization
what if the test asks you to match n
name to any earth now what is your
expected number of correct answers can
you figure it out give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for the solution
so before I solve this problem I'm going
to go over the question of how many
different ways are there to get on the
test now many people would guess what's
known as the permutation this is where
you match each name to a different year
so how many different permutations of
five things are there or how many
different ways are there to match each
name to a different year let's start
counting the first name can be matched
to any of five different year one of
these choices is going to be your guests
now the next name can be matched to any
of the four remaining choices one of
these is also going to be your guests
now the next name will have a
possibility of three different years and
once again one of these is going to be
your choice so we see a pattern here the
next name is going to have two possible
choices once you make your choice
the last name will have only one
possible choice so we can count the
total number of possible ways to guess
by multiplying each of these options we
have five times four times three times
two times one which is equal to five
factorial or 120 different ways to get
now if we have a test with n items the
same pattern will apply so we're going
to have n factorial ways to get on a
test with an item now this is going to
be a lot of different ways to get we're
not going to want to enumerate all the
different ways and count how many
correct answers there are and then take
the average you could do that on a
computer but we don't need to do that
and in fact the number of ways you could
guess is actually even more suppose that
you allow repetition where you say that
you could match multiple names to the
same year how many different ways are
there to guess now well the first name
can be matched to any of the five years
the next name can be matched to any of
the five years
so on every single name can be matched
to any of the five years so we have five
different choices where we have five
different years so the total number of
possibilities is five multiplied by
itself five times which is 5 to the
power of five or three thousand one
hundred and twenty five ways to get on a
test with n items the pattern is similar
each of the N item has n different
choices so there will be n to the power
of n ways to get so even if you could
compute this on a computer algorithm you
wouldn't want to do it when n gets very
large so how are we going to solve this
problem we're going to consider a
probability principle so let's start out
by asking how often is the first name
matched to the correct year well think
about it there are n possible years so
on average there's going to be a 1 in n
champ that you match that first name to
the correct year well what's so special
about the first name in fact any single
name has a 1 over n chance of matching
on average you know the first name that
you match that's just a random choice so
you could make any of the names the
first name and still by symmetry each
name has a 1 over n chance of matching
on average now what we'll do is we'll
define a random variable X sub K that
equals 1 if the case name is matched to
the correct here and it equals 0
otherwise so why are we doing this why
are we making the problem seemingly more
complicated it's because we're going to
use a property of random variables and
the expectation operator what we want to
compute is we want to compute the
expected number of correct answers which
is the expectations' of the sum of all
these random variables now the key is
that the expectation operator has a
special property if you have two random
variables then the expectation of X plus
y
equal to the expectation of X plus the
expectation Y this is known as the
linearity of the expectation operator
and with very important to us is that it
works even if x and y are not
specifically independent so for example
let's say you're matching two items to
two years you know if you match the
first item incorrectly the second item
is necessarily going to be matched
incorrectly because it's art it's answer
choice has been taken if you're doing a
permutation so the key is that this
linearity the expectation operator works
even if the variables are not
statistically independent so let's apply
this property we want the expectation of
a sum of random variables and that's
going to equal the sum of the
expectation now what are each of these
expectations well e of X sub one is the
expectation that we have the first name
to be matched and E of X sub K is the
expectation that we have the case name
match well by symmetry we figured out
each of these is going to be equal to 1
over n each name has a 1 over n chance
of matching on average so we can
substitute in 1 over n for each of these
variables we now have n terms that are 1
over n so it'll be an average of 1 and
that our correct answer in a matching
test with n items you average one
correct answer by guessing so this is a
really interesting fact because it
doesn't matter if the test has two items
or if the test is a million item you're
going to average one if you guess
randomly furthermore we've gone over
that the different ways that you could
guess randomly on the test and this is
gonna be the same average the one way is
imagine you get each name to all of the
names to single year you know you say
all of your choices just go to the first
year you're guaranteed obviously that
one correct answer because one of the
mathematicians will get to the correct
year so what's interesting about this
method is that
your average is going to be one but
you're always going to get that one
correct answer you're also going to get
all the other answers incorrect so the
other way you could guess is you might
you know match each name to a different
year you might try and guess the
permutation the problem here is there's
actually a 37% chance or approximately
37% chance that you might miss all of
the question this sort of arrangement
where each item is matched to the wrong
to a wrong year is known as the
derangement and it turns out there's a
37% chance of having a derangement if
you're interested in how to derive that
percentage I've provided a link I went
over this in the secret danced video so
there are different ways you can get
randomly so on average you're going to
get one correct answer and if you just
need one correct answer to pass the test
and to go on you might as well put all
the names matching to a single year but
if you need more than one you're
probably better off guessing a
permutation because although once in a
while there's a 37% chance you might
miss all them there is probably a good
chance that you're going to get more
than one correct
did you figure out this problem thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on maps and
game theory you can catch on my blog
mind your decisions that you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch it on social media at pressure
Walker if you liked this video please
check out my book there are links in the
video description